- [Voiceover] Each year,
a group of statisticians
polled 1,500 randomly
selected United States adults
with the question,
"Are the Democratic and Republican parties
"doing an adequate job,
"or is a third major
political party needed?"
The scatter plot above
shows the percentage
of U. S. adults polled
between the years 2004
and 2014 that think that a third major
political party is needed.
Based on the line of best fit,
the line of best fit,
to the data shown,
which of the following values
is closest to the average yearly change,
average yearly change,
in the percentage of people that think
a third major political
party is necessary?
All right, so let's see,
let's look at this chart here.
It tells us percentage of U. S. adults
that think a third major
political party is necessary.
When you look at the actual
plot right over here,
the scatter plot,
that in year zero,
so this would be in 2004,
it looks like it's around,
I don't know, 42% roughly.
Then we get to about 45% in 2005.
This is year one,
or one year since 2004,
so this would be 2005.
It keeps increasing all the way
until we get to three years since 2004,
or four years since,
actually no, this is
three years since 2004.
So this would be 2007.
Then it drops a little bit.
Then it increases, increases,
drops a little bit, then it increases.
Then they have this line of best fit.
This line of best fit,
one way to think about it
is the slope of this line of best fit
is one way to think about
the average yearly
change in the percentage
of people that think that a third major
political party is necessary.
Now when you look at this,
it looks like the slope of this line,
it looks like it goes up,
it looks like it's going up,
I don't know,
from this point,
I'm just picking points that I can look
clearly at the grid,
from that point to this point,
it's gone up 10%.
It's gone up from 45 to 55%.
So this has gone up 10%.
And how many years did it take it
to go up 10%?
Well let's see.
It took it, let's see this is year one,
it goes up to year nine,
it looks like it took
approximately eight years
to go up approximately 10%.
This is a positive 10%.
The on average, it looks like,
if we look at the line of best fit,
it looks like an increasing.
Every year that goes by,
on average, more and more U. S. adults
think that a third major
political party is necessary.
This is, of course, the line of best fit.
When we look at the actual scatter plot,
it jumps around a little bit more.
Sometimes it goes down or up,
but if we look at the line of best fit,
it is an increasing trend.
So what's the slope of
this right over here?
Well we increased 10%
in eight years.
So this is going to be equals,
see, 10% in eight years
is about 1.25,
and this an approximation,
so let me put an
approximation right over here,
so approximately 1.25% per year.
And it's clearly increasing.
It's going from the bottom
left to the top right.
Now let's look at our
choices right over here.
So we can immediately rule out
the choices that have a decreasing,
I mixed up decreasing and declining,
a declining percentage.
The percentage on the line of best fit,
it's increasing, we have a positive slope.
And I said it's approximately 1.25%.
That's pretty close to
this one right over here.
The reason why there is some imprecision
over here is because I just eyeballed it.
I just eyeballed this
chart right over here.
I said okay, this looks
like it's about eight years.
It actually might have covered 10%
and a little bit less than eight years,
so there's a little imprecision over here.
So these are all approximations,
but even with the approximations I got,
I got very close.
I got very close to this answer,
and much closer to this answer
than I'd got to any of the other ones.